呃，这次选的这个片子啊，金石漂流记是这几年啊。
韩国电影里面。
韩国电影当然出了非常非常多优秀的作品啊。
但是单就剧本而言，金世漂流记啊绝对有它的。
这个一席之地啊呃就是它集合了创意和工整两两方面啊，它既非常有创意，然后呢也非常工整。
嗯，还蛮教科书一般的存在啊。另外这部电影还有一个什么特点呢？是韩国电影里面为数不多的。
直接扒过来就能拍的。
咱们有一段时间啊，咱们中国几乎所有的喜剧电影公司都在疯狂的去抢购韩国版权啊，不瞒大家说这个版权我也去买过，因为这个剧本确实是呃非常好，而且是受到业内大家的一个认可啊，所以说这个呃带着大家看一下这部片子啊。
我们先看节拍，我先说一遍，咱们花点时间把节拍说一遍啊，每次这个节拍啊都需要花半个小时给大家讲。但是我们同学们要知道，这是我们拉片的基础啊，我们需要理清楚所有这个故事所有的信息推进啊，我们才能知道这个故事后续的一些知识点。
这个故事的节拍啊，拉过的同学可以跟着我一块对一对，我们先不去分四目啊。
第一排。
第一分钟。
主角在打电话啊，用一通电话交代主角的困境啊，困境是什么呢？欠债。
主要困境啊，因为他还还涉及不到现状。因为现状呢，其实后面又继续补充交代了。在这里先交代了他的最大的一个困境就是他欠债。因为是这也是他要呃跳河自杀的一个原因。所以第一拍就是用一通电话啊，他打电话交代这个这个这个他的。
主角上来先交代困境，这个同学们自己也要记一下啊，有时候上来啊，主角的现状也不是那么着急，先都铺开。
同学们有没有想过一个问题，如果是你写这个戏，你第一场搞不好就写，他在公司被老板骂是吧？回到家又被女朋友撵出来。
就把现状全部交代一下，就有点像药神那种交代方式。
我没有说药神那种交代方式不好啊，但是我们可以看一下呃这个片子他这种交代方式好吧，一通电话先把主要困境说了，现状待会儿再说，先把主要困境说了，他要跳河自杀的原因，先先跳再说。
啊，对，大家喜欢哪一种不重要啊。那个我们就先说人家这个故事，他的这种处理方式，因为他后面有有办法来交代前十，所以说他就没有做这件事情。
第二趴第二分钟他没死成啊没死成。
没死成呢，他肯定是想继续死呀。在这里他有个重要的目标啊，他觉得跳河死这件事情不靠谱，他要跳楼，跳什么楼呢？跳六三大厦啊，应该是当时最高的楼吧，相当于咱们的这个这个类似于中国尊之类的东西啊。然后结果呢发现这是个。
湖心岛啊根本走不出去，这是第二拍。
第三拍。
来到第5分钟，他尝试离开这个地方，对吧呼救报警，打电话给前女友，反正各种方法都失败了，最后被被一通推销电话，是吧，给手机干没电了。
这里呢也侧面交代了我们主角懦弱的性格啊。嗯，这个相信很多同学都有同感啊，有时候明明是骚扰电话，你都不好意思挂。
咱们有没有同学有这种有这种情况的？
嗯，有很多人啊，他由于特别像我们搞创作的同学啊呃共由于共情能力比较强，呃，特别喜欢替别人着想啊，也可以说是呃用用他们成功学的话说，可能就是比较自卑啊。但是咱们不认可这种说法，共情力强。嗯，从成功学的角度说是自卑。但是从我们创作的角度反而是优势啊我。
是不在意嗯我们这个心软呀、共情力强这件事情的啊，我觉得可以变成优势。
呃，在这里呢也是个小细节啊，我们的主角就是这么一个心软的人啊。
那咱们有很多同学应该也是这样啊，因为咱们是搞创作的嘛，很正常，不用自卑啊呃千万不要这个这个觉得哎呀，我我我这个会阻碍我的成功啊，咱们同学不用这么想啊，来第四拍第10分钟尝试游泳啊，尝试游泳回到现实社会。但是。
嗯，差点淹死差点淹死。我们说刚才没交代，不是没交代现状吗？没交代前十吗？没交代这个主角是怎么一步一步走到现在的吗？
在这个烟水的这个恍惚之际，用一组蒙太奇交代了他跟父亲的关系，他和工作的关系，他和爱情的关系以及。
他和高利贷的关系记不记得正如蒙太奇啊，待会儿可以一起看一下啊。
好，第五拍。
来到第14分钟，回到岸上啊。
嗯，既然走不了，他决定在岛上啊了解自己，在岛上自杀啊。
这时候想起了防空演习的警报，同学们记住啊，防空演习的警报在这个故事当中非常的呃非常的有用啊。防在这里第一次想起了防空演习的警报。呃，在这个片子当中，他交代过首尔这个或者是韩国这个地方啊，他一年要搞两次这个防空演习。
一次在春天一次在秋天。在咱们的故事当中呢，一次在故事的第一天，一次在故事的第二天，用春天从播种到收获的两次防空演习穿起了整个故事。
而且防空演习在这个故事当中，对于两个人的意义都非常重大。同学们记住这个重要的东西啊，防空演习这个重要的东西不用研究它是什么隐喻，我们只研究它是什么作用就可以了啊。以后你要记住，呃，在你的故事当中有这种固定时间具有标志性意义的事件啊，作为一个节点的一个。
划分和考量是非常好用的啊非常。
而而且人家说了啊，人家一年有两次这个防控演习，一次在春天，一次在冬天啊，一次是播种的季节，一次是收获的季节。两个人呢都是在同一天播种了希望啊，也在同一天收获了希望，好吧。
呃，继续回到这个第五拍啊，防控演习多说了几句，他在这里呢，他因因为走不了了，他决定在这个岛上自我了结是吧？上吊。
结果呢呃被什么打断呢？被这个变异啊突然想拉屎。
然后呢呃拉屎的时候发现了美好的花朵啊，美丽的单生花，美味的单生花啊品尝，然后带来了触动崩溃啊。呃，在这里呢他痛哭了一场，嗯，实际上表达的意思呢就是他不想死了啊不想死。
然后来到第六拍，第18分钟，他既然决定活下去啊，他就开始享受这个另类的自由和解脱，然后开始喝水呀、吃蘑菇呀、钻木取火什么的啊。
然后来到第七拍，第20分钟啊。
晚上呢开始和城市啊叫嚣啊，在这里啊大家记住啊。
他在第20分钟的时候，第七拍啊跟城市叫嚣啊。
因为自己是个弃儿嘛，所以他脱了衣服，脱了裤子，雄性的动物啊。
这个刻在基因里的向对方示威啊，会会干什么啊？
这个。
呃，实际上就是一个向现代文明告别的一个仪式。
在第20分钟就出仪式了啊，自己记一下啊。
第20分钟第七拍的时候，这里就有一个。
仪式感。
实际上可以代表上路了啊，可以实际上可以代表上路了。
因为他呢这在这里啊像。
现代文明示威啊示威。
第八拍来到第22分钟啊，开始捡破烂儿，在这里捡到了一个非常重要的道具，捡了一个什么呀？
捡了一个家啊，捡了一个捡了一套房。
捡了一套房。
而且这里有句台词其实挺扎心的，同学们记不记得？
在这里有记台词啊，就韩国的这个编剧，韩国的创作者想要讽刺韩国的高房价以及普通人的收入低。他说，攒钱攒了7年，竟然买不到一套房。
这个这几个台词其实挺扎心的啊，他是没有到我们这儿来看一看，攒个70年是吧？
7年前竟然想买房嗯，第八拍这里啊还有一个重要的东西，就是他捡了这个房子之后啊，他这个生活品质提升了啊，他的那个求救那个help也变成了问号啊，变成了hello啊。
来到第九拍，来到第23分钟啊，第九拍第23分钟啊，这里开始游戏时间了啊，捉鱼捉鸭、捉鸟掏蛋啊，至于这里是不是游戏时间，我们当然还是可以讨论啊。但是从男主的角度，这里是男主的游戏时间。
自记一下啊，第九拍第23分钟。
他在里捉鱼捉鸭，抓鸟掏蛋啊。
而且在意外情况下还获取了蛋白质，开始享受极致的生活啊，开始享受这个极致的生活了。
来到第十拍，27分钟啊，27分钟。
女主登场啊啊或者是我们定位他这个男的叫老金啊，这个女的叫小金啊，小金登场了啊，是不是女主可以再讨论啊？小金登场啊。
是女主还是是爱情待会讨论。那角色登场显然是介绍困境和现状啊。在这里呢女主的这里就不啰嗦了啊，她的现状和困境一股脑儿的用了六七分钟交代了个完完整整，彻彻底底啊。因为女主在这里登场也比较晚嘛啊再加上这个故事啊本身叙事节奏偏慢。
嗯，我们的男主那边呢也没有配合的角色，没有办法有对手戏。所以在这里竟然花了7分钟交代女主的现状、困境啊所有的东西。
女主是个啥呢？
女主是个自闭的是吧？显然是一个社恐，甚至涉呃不止社恐了，自闭了。
自闭的女博主啊过着一个虚假的生活，对吧？在网上创造了一个幻境，这是她的一个一个一个一个情况，而且已经三年没出门了，是吧？保持着很另类的生活。
很另类的自律，而且展现了他完整的一天是怎么过下来。
所以花了点时间。
来到第1一拍，也就是第4034分钟啊。
这个我们从这里看可以看到女主的这条时间线啊是又倒回去重新说的。因为又来了那个防空演习日啊，我们说你看这个东西它不是作用就来了吗？
同学们理解这个意思吧？
每年两次的这个防空演习日，对他来说很重要。因为他每年这用这两次的时间见官，因为他感觉这20分钟呢世界静止了，他是可以跟外界进行沟通的。
同时也交代了，哎，女主这条时间线呢其实是又往回倒了倒是吧？是我们主角刚刚跳楼的那条时间线，明白吗？
刚刚跳楼的那个时间节点，对吧？
然后呢。
啊，他用望远镜发现了这个男主，甚至以为这个男主是这个啥是外星人是吧？
嗯，发发现了男主。
来到第12拍36分钟啊，我们的女主失眠了啊呃，因为她的这个平静的三年的这个一成不变的生活呃，忍不住被打破了。因为他要查看这个男主的情况，开始对男主进行观察，甚至有一个隔空帮助男主的名场面啊，那个那个名察面是剪进预告片的啊。
呃，记不记得那个名场面？
在那个屏幕上推了一下那个男主的那个小鸭子啊，我们说呃这种情况啊，这种画面啊都是名场面啊，剪进这个。
剪进这个这个这个预告片里的啊嗯，同时在这里强调一下啊。
几乎是每周都带着大家练习信息差。
这部电影算是把信息差用到极致了。
对不对？
嗯，有人在暗中观察男主，甚至在暗中帮助他，对吧？但我们的主角不知道。
啊，我们观众是知道的，虽然这个主角从防空警报响起的这个时间点，他干了些什么，我们看过了。
但是我们随着女主的视角再看一遍的时候，依然没有觉得无聊。
这就是信息差的魅力，对吧？天天苦口婆心的带着大家练习信息差练习在这部电影里面啊有一个非常好的一个体现啊。
第十三拍来到39分钟。
男主在海岛啊活的越来越好了，对吧？甚至打上高尔夫了是吧？在海岛实现了阶层跃迁，而且还夸自己go shot是吧？打得好。
过得很好，还有有有一个很标志性的一场戏来表达了一下，就是什么呢？就是有船从这儿经过啊，它躲起来。
证明什么啊？
不想回到现实了啊，在这儿过得嗨死了，开心死了。
来到第十四趴。
来到第十四排。
捡到一份炸酱面调料啊，勾起了一个新的目标。
勾起了思念啊，做梦都是炸酱面。我们说这是一产生了一个新的目标，好不容易过好了啊，产生一个新目标，目标不能断呀，对不对？我们说主线目标当然是在这个岛先活下去，但是呢你总得拆解成具体目标嘛，没有具体目标，它也没有动力了嘛。所以在这里啊拆了一个非常具体的目标，甚至是。
贯穿到第贯穿到。
第二目呃第三目的一个目标啊，相当于是。
你可以理解。
把它蹬倒。我们说一个人在荒岛生存活下去当然是主线目标。但是不具体啊，做炸酱面反而成了第二幕里面确立的主角的一个主线目标，或者是男主这条线确立的一个主线目标。这个我们先把话只说到这儿，先把它放在这儿，待会儿再讨论啊。
做梦都是炸酱面啊，来到第15拍42分钟啊，他开始尝试做面条，失败后啊。
呃，甚至各种后悔他自己以前不珍惜炸酱面这个事儿。
然后石榴牌44分钟。
呃，发现鸟屎是可以了啊，发现鸟屎这个新的一个希望，开始收集鸟屎呃，开始农耕啊，当然了也需要克服各种困难啊。
呃，同时再次强调一下，这里呢呃由于把视角切回到我们男主，这里也给了一些女主观察的一些主观视角。意思是什么呢？继续把这个时间差呃，把这个信息差啊，把这个信息差提醒观众。
让观众知道这一切从现在开始，这一切都是在女主的注视下完成的啊。这里用镜头是交代了一下的。
17拍来到第49分钟。
当时开始想死的时候，他不是用上吊绳吗？
那个上吊绳其实是他的领带，也就是说他把上吊绳拆回来，重新变成了领带，代表了他啊呃不想死了，要要活下去。另外呢他把自己的躯壳。
做成了稻草人。
我再说一遍啊。
男主把自己的躯壳。
他全套的衣服、裤子。
衬衫领带做成了一个稻草人。
而他自己。
获得了真正的自由啊。
他把自己的躯壳啊代表束缚他的那些衬衣领带。
西服啊做成了一个稻草人，他自己反而获得了真正的自由啊，反而获得了真正的自由。这是一个很标准的有象征意义的戏啊，给大家看一下，甚至把钱包啊都放在躯壳里了，他自己获得了彻底的解脱。
同学们看这样的画面啊，同学们去看看一下这样的画面，镜头缓缓的往上推啊，代表主角从这个躯壳里面啊缓缓的走出来。当然了，镜头不是我们需要去考虑的问题，但是同学们要知道啊，像这种戏的设计啊，都是非常漂亮的啊，非常漂亮啊，这种戏设计的太漂亮。
这个画面完美的诠释了主我们的主角和他过去的旧的躯壳告别了啊告别了。
来。
第十八拍啊第十八拍来到第50分钟，这时候啊女主已经观察我们的男主俩月了啊，发现了这个呃当然了，他也发现了这个我们这个外星人啊对炸酱面是很执着的是吧？很执着炸酱面。然后呢，当然了两个人也继续隔空互动。
来到第1九拍，52分钟啊，52分钟女主啊冒险出街全副武装干什么嘞？
向小岛投递了漂流瓶，他想要跟我们的男主不是隔空互动的问题了，是要真正的取得联系。他冒险啊在打破自己的生活轨迹了，女主打破自己的生活轨迹啊，虽然全副武装，但是确实冒险打破了。
投递了漂流瓶。
来到第20分钟啊，第20拍也就是57分钟，3个月以后了，直接3个月以后啊，这个漂流瓶3个月也没动静。
男主生活的更加安逸了啊，他这时候爬树呀、钓鱼呀、泡茶呀都很熟练，而且农田里还长出了一棵幼苗，代表着美好的希望。
来到第21拍59分钟。
发现了漂流瓶，知道有人在观察自己啊，决定做出回应。两个人开始一个人用漂流瓶，一个用沙滩上的大的英文字，两个人取得了联系。
我们说一切都在往美好的方向发展，是吧？
来到第22拍，也就是63分钟。
继续漂流瓶啊。
然后这次呢。
这个这个女主再一次冒险出街的时候呢，呃这次有一个重要的变化，她开始发现了世间的美好。
记不记得那场戏啊，第二次女主蒙面出街的时候，发现了世间的美好鲜花和蝴蝶。
我们说如果这一次他再次蒙面出街没有变化的话，实际是没有必要拍出来的。
懂我意思吧？
因为再拍一遍就成重复信息了，他怎么戴头盔，怎么蒙怎么蒙混过关，怎么用雨伞，怎么快步跑，怎么趁黑夜，怎么躲车，对吧？
如果是再重复，实际上没有必要再拍一遍了，这次再拍一遍，就是为了表达啊他这次开始有变化了，他开始观察到发现到世间的美好。我们说像这种片子。
标准的就是互相治愈的片子，对不对？非常标准互相治愈的片子。所以说这个他慢慢被治愈啊，也是情理之中的。
23拍也就是64分钟啊，两个人继续用最简单的英文去交流啊，为什么在这里用非常简单的英文去交流啊？现实意义当然是英文比较好刻在沙滩上啊。但是其实最重要的是什么呢？最重要的是想讲。
人与人之间的沟通啊，实际语言并没没有那么重要。两个人沟通了大半年，从春天到秋天就说了点。
hello是吧？how are you那个fine thank youand you是吧？两个人的交流停留在停留在小学二年级第一课。所以说呃想这个这个语言其实并不重要啊并不重要。
另外呢与此同时啊第23拍这里与此同时啊一颗玉米已经长成了啊，一颗玉米已经长成了。我们的主角呢呃非常的欢欣鼓舞啊，和自己的去壳一起庆祝这件事情。
来到第24排啊，67分钟。
女主给男主点了外卖啊，因为女主发现这个男主执着于炸酱面以后呢，女主认为有更简单的方法，对不对？一步到位。
然后呢，让外卖小哥去给他送外卖。
但是我们的男主拒绝。
男主拒绝，但这次一次重要的沟通，虽然面条没有送到位，但是男主呢想知道女主的样子，女主想知道男主说了什么，两个人隔通过一个人通过一个外卖小哥进行了一个比较高效率的沟通，不是那个how are you?I'm fine，thank you那种沟通了啊，两个人进行了一次高效沟通。
借助这个呃神级演技的外卖小哥啊。
另外呢女主也知道了，炸酱面啊，其实不是炸酱面，是希望。
两个人都通过这件事情有了比较大的突破和改变。甚至呢我们的女主也改变了自己一成不变的菜单，品尝了炸酱面的味道。为什么呢？因为他要品尝什么是希望？我们说。
这又是一个故事节点啊，故事这节点。
来到第25排74分钟，玉米长成了，玉米我们说希望长成了。然后女主呢同时也也也也有了希望了，开始跟妈妈交流了啊。我们说自闭症啊是避免跟人交流的啊，她连眼神接触都要避免，所以说她要戴头盔，她要躲那个保安大爷，因为保安大爷又不跟你说话，你为什么要躲呢？实际上是躲眼神交流啊。
自闭症是躲避眼神交流的，女主呢竟然和妈妈自己当面交流了啊，让妈妈很惊喜。
来到第26排77分钟啊，两个人继续用漂流瓶交流着啊，感情也继续升温，甚至开始画画了啊，开始搞怪，开始开玩笑了。
27拍78分钟到了收获的季节啊，玉米收获了，磨成面做成了炸酱面，拿出了珍藏已久的调料啊。我们的男主终于吃到了珍这个渴望已久的炸酱面，嗯，吃吃的这个又哭又笑啊，又哭又笑。
第二八拍。
第28拍来到82分钟，女主也收获了希望啊，开始逐步回归正常。
女主也收获收获希望，对吧？也有很多标志性的一些。当然了，也有很多细节的戏啊，比如说不在衣橱里睡觉了啊，开始从衣橱里出来了是吧？先不用走向世界，先从衣橱里走出来嘛，对吧？女主也开始收获了很多改变啊，逐步开始。
往回归正常的路上走啊。
来到第29拍，84分钟啊。
两个人的感情开始升温啊，两个人都收获了希望，也都收获了改变。两个人的感情也开始升温。男主甚至拿出手机模拟给这个女主。
呃，这个这个联系甚至发出了想跟你见面这个这样的邀请啊，开始模拟。
我们说由于这个故事它设计的比较特别，男女主角一直不能相见，所以说会有这样的一些呃。
独角戏啊会有这样一些独角戏存在，大家也不要觉得奇怪。
第30拍来到86分钟啊，女主啊女主也在种植玉米吗？
女主也在种植玉米。
但是这时候男主发出了一个。
直击女主最大困境，心灵最痛楚的一个问题就是who are you.
对吧你是谁？
我们女主最大的困境就是认同危机啊，认同危机。她由于认为自己长得不好看，对吧？没有自信，所以说她一直活在互联网上啊，她活在这个元宇宙里，用另外一张另外一种身份或者另外一些身份在生存着。
所以说我们的女主实际上她最大的问题就是她根本不知道自己是谁。现在。
他作为谁能在这个世界上存在，他自己其实并不太知道啊，他这个假身份并不太知道。所以在这个男主向他发出了哇又这个这个问题，看似很简单的问题，实际上是呃对我们的女主是最难回答的一个问题之后，我们的女主呢习惯性的在网上选了一个自己的假身份。
自己的假身份。
打印出来了，但是呢没有最终还是没有投递出去。因为那几个照片并不是他自己，所以他最终没有投递出去。
两个人的感情啊开始破裂了，两个人的感情破裂了啊，在这里就是啊破裂了。
然后第31分钟来到呃第31拍，来到89分钟啊。呃男主再次拷问这个女主为什么啊，为什么不愿面对自己啊？女主。
不光不愿意面对男主，也不愿面对自己啊，决定跟男主断绝关系，再次封闭啊，再次封闭了自己，再次回被打回了原形嗯。
女主这条线啊进入灵魂黑夜。
因为他不光被打回了原形啊，呃他不光和男主这边破裂，被打回原形。他在网上精心打造的虚假身份也被网友戳穿了啊，也被网黑呃，那个也被人网报了，假身份被戳穿啊，被网爆。
三十二拍。
第91分钟啊，然后这个我们说灵魂黑夜一般要下大雨啊，灵魂黑夜一般要下大雨，嗯，配合了一场暴雨。我们男主的这条线啊，男主的这条线，农田，包括代表他家的那个房房子，包括他的那个稻草人的躯壳。
这三个最有农田代表希望家那个小鸭子代表家是吧？它的那个躯壳代表他原本的身份全部都被摧毁了啊，全都被摧毁了。
男男女主各自的呃这个这个故事线，以及他们两个人的感情线同时进入了灵魂黑夜啊，第三十2排同时进入灵魂黑夜。我们说灵魂黑夜啊一般来说都下大雨啊。
来到第33趴，95分钟，风雨过后呢，女主开始牵挂我们的男主。
当然了，通过他的视角去观察，也发现我们的男主确实遇到问题了，遇到谁呀，遇到城管了。
是吧咱们知道应该翻译成什么？我们就理解为城管吧啊，34拍。
97分钟啊，一场这个追逐戏啊，一场追逐戏之后，我们的主男主被抓住了啊，被抓住了，被驱赶。但他这时候啊除了。
嗯，不想离开他的这个世外桃源以外。
他想留在这里，还有一个重要的原因啊，还是因为这段感情，他想留在这里等到他那个人的答复，那个跟他失去联络的人的答复。
因为他如果离开这里，从他的角度去思考，他有可能跟这个支持了他大半年的人。
彻底失去了联系，彻底绝裂了，对吧？彻底找不到了，因为他们是通过漂流瓶联系的。
35拍啊，来到101分钟。
我们的主角被迫离开小岛啊，渐行渐远。我们的女主这时候也害怕永远的失去这个男主，因为女主也找不到这个所谓的外星人了嘛。
然后呢，他终于鼓起勇气走出了家门。我们说患难见真情，前面灵魂黑夜的时候，两个人感情打到底，对吧？感情打到底，我们说那叫误会加决裂，对不对？我们说产生了误会就决裂了。那最后怎么把感情加拉回来啊，患难真情啊，一方有难啊，另外一方面见真情，我们的男主。
呃，被迫离开小岛，渐行渐远之后，我们女主终于走出家门奔向男主。
第36拍104分钟，我们把女主奔向男主来拯救男主的意义继续放大，为什么嘞？
男主这时候想干什么啊？男主回到文明世界，穿上那层束缚他的西装领带，那套躯壳以后。
他要干什么？
打回原形。
他要再次去到63号大厦，了结自己，他要去跳楼。
然后嘞，我们的女主这时候去追赶他，意义就更重大了。因为去拯救他的生命啊，我们的男主被打回现实世界之后，他。
他的美梦结束了，他要继续去继续去死啊，继续去死。
我们来看一下啊。
他上车。
不你的。
我们说在这里为什么要笑啊？
我们说这里男主角为什么要苦笑一下？
因为交通卡啊，就是说电子产品、芯片这种东西啊是属于现代文明。
我们说。
他回到现代文明啊，现代文明所有的东西都只能送他去死。
他逃离现代生命，现代文明反而能活下去啊。回到现代文明，他现在想要去死都得刷卡。
不禁让我们想起网上比较流行的一句话啊，就是所谓普通人就是。
盛世的牛马，乱世的炮灰啊，盛世的牛马乱世的炮灰。
我们的主角啊回到现实，只有死路一条。
甚至想去自杀啊，都得依靠交通卡。
好。
我们的女主呢在这场戏里面追逐这个公交车失败了啊。在第36拍104分钟这一坨戏里面，我们的女主去追逐公交车，追赶公交车，失败了。我们说这里也是个信息插，女主虽然不知道男主要自杀，但是她呢是要去。
呃，去见这个男主，他怕他永远的失去他。
呃，但是我们观众是知道这个男主是要自杀的，所以我们非常希望这个女主追上这个男主。
这也是一个信息差啊，这也是个信息差。
然后追逐失败啊追逐失败。
来到第37趴108分钟。
什么代表带来了转机呢？
中演戏。
防空练习再次让世界安静了。
我们的女主啊奔向了。
公交车。
走向了我们的男主。
说了句英文啊，简单的台词，直击心灵。
这也是名场面啊，结尾就停在这儿了啊嗯非常短促，非常干净的结尾就这么收掉了啊。嗯，当然了，我们也可以再探讨续这个电影啊开的比较短促，开场的时候啊没有什么现状，非常短促，结束的时候呢也非常短促啊。
没有什么后续这个呃这个两两人就牵了一个手啊，就牵了一个手就结束了。
这就是这个故事的整个节拍。我们先把几个名场面回顾一下啊，我们呃也不叫名场面嘛，就是比较有作用的细啊。我们看一下第四节拍的前十的那个蒙太奇。
我们说他用一组蒙太奇交代所有的前十啊，来我们看一下。
给你可别八唧级。
초서대拍 쳤으면서 다 너야 돼?
你出什了，你的看臭幽0你처럼。
你哼。
나시.
快枪等枪。
不。
发动。
된光는데.
자기야 못된 거랑 문한 거랑 어떻게 다 본지 아니야?
有点大。
不在的。
주路엠切 이엠지.
嗯嗯。
我们说这场戏啊。
也是呃交代前史的戏里面比较让人印象深刻的一场戏啊，通过溺水又产生了这个恍惚之际，这时候出幻觉呢比较合理，对不对？否则你凭空在那儿出幻觉，那不成了那种了啊，成了这个。
呃，闪回系了。
当然啦，这也是闪会系。
但是它比较巧妙的啊。
用一个溺水，然后不断的探出头来见到新的人。你看同学们，你你你们仔细想一下，我为什么在日常的练习当中或者是创作当中呃是不提倡你们用闪灰的。因为你们有时候一用闪灰啊，就这个男主坐在河边看着世间的繁华，然后默默流下眼泪。我。
这个人生的一幕幕涌上心头，多掉节奏啊，是不是？你看人家。
很很巧妙的，是想闪回，是想讲几场前面的前史。但是呢咦这个人家把这个非常巧妙的融合在这个逆水系里了。
这不就蛮好。
学一学啊学一学来。
再来看一场啊这个戏当中。
也是剪辑预告片的一个。
一个戏就是这个男主啊，我们说这个演员啊，他其实是一个非常优秀的喜剧演员啊，所以他的表演他有点像腾哥是吧，演啥都带喜剧。所以说在这个戏当中，他在人生第一次感动嗯，他决定活下来的那场戏，记不记得？
同学们，他决定活下来那场戏是尝到尝到的单身花是吧？本来是一场挺感人的戏，对不对？以以美丽的花朵，美好的味道，美好的回忆，让他有了活下去的勇气。结果呢他在那拉屎。
而且是一边哭一边拉是吧？
我们说这种这种这种戏啊，也就是这个大哥才能。
看一看啊。
蹲着往前走是吧？
我看一下这场戏。
。
演技实在是太好了啊，演技实在是太好了。我们说这个演员在韩国经常获得这个演技的大奖啊，确实是确实非常厉害。我们再看一下他吃面的那个那个戏吧。好吧，再看一下他的演技的名场面啊，因为吃面那个戏他需要又笑又哭又吃，所以说还是蛮蛮蛮。
蛮有挑战的啊，呃那场戏也是这个这个演员的一个巅峰演技啊，我们来看一下吧。
我们说这是主角啊，主角大在几个关键节点的这个戏啊，我们说演技这个东西啊，同学们一定不要。
片面的理解为说一个角色他能哭，或者是他的爆发力很强，就是好的演技。实际上真正的好演员是不追求这个东西的。
好演员就是真正的进入这个角色。
他就会去体会这个角色真正该想什么一个角色，一个一个角色。我们说一个人啊。
他在自杀以后对吧，被逼入绝境。自杀以后，在一个荒岛生活了大半年，用自己的双手想尽了各种办法。
种出了一碗炸酱面啊，他在吃到这场炸酱面的时候，他的情感。
他的情感啊是很自然的一个。
自然的一个流露啊，在这时候他只要是真的这个演员，他只要是真的进入到这个角色。那根据演员的状态，他想哭想笑。
其实作为这个这个这个导演，不需要他去干涉他，他是先哭再笑，还是先笑再哭，还是先哭再笑再哭，还是先笑再哭再笑，这个都是呃不需要去设计的啊，实际上是不需要去设计的。
当然了，在这个电影里面，我们说还有一个非常抢戏的角择，那个外卖小哥其实外卖小哥这种角色也不好演啊，由于他没有前史，他没有复杂的这个人物人物背景。
没有时间去交代，也不给人家戏份。
只是让他来演个这个吧这个呃。
外卖小哥，然后这个外卖小哥呢又恰好是个精神小伙是吧？打这个耳钉，染这个头发，外戴个帽子。实际上你可以理解是一个韩国这种小小该溜子精神小伙啊，我们说这个角色实际上演的也非常好，我们可以看一下这个角色，好吧。今天嗯今天咱们也反正也不着急啊，多陪一会儿大家啊。
演的也是着实不错啊着实不错。我们说这种戏啊，你像如果是国内拍的话，你们想一想，如果这个电影是你拍国内拍，那这种角色你找谁去演不好找，你知道吧？找杨迪对吧？未必能演出来啊。如果是我的话，我应该会找大鹏老师来帮个忙。
啊，精神小伙这个状态啊。
点对。
有。
也克审。
都有。
여자 어떤 여자 어떻게 생겼세요 더 상당히 보시요 저 태 오늘 된지?
喜欢吃的是是。
好。
这个这呦。
치긴 한데.
对。
다어요뭐라고 하는 거 같은데 오 됐요 돈요?
所说这个小哥啊短短的几场戏啊，确实是给观众留下了很多印象啊。
嗯，我们再来看一下这个故事的结局啊，比较干净的这一场。嗯好，我们说这个啊嗯首先这几场是有几个可以学习的地方啊。首先这个呃结束的非常的当然了用这个。
防空演习啊做一个很好的呼应，然后结束的非常痛快啊。两个人是因为什么断开的呀？就是我问你你是谁？所以这个女孩回答了自己是谁，解了这个套啊，然后这个戏就非常。
非常干净利索的结束了。我们说这个戏开头也很干净，结尾也很干净啊。在这里我们探讨一个问题啊。
我在当年看这部戏的时候。
我非常希望这部戏结束在哪儿呢？
就这个女孩儿。
慢慢的走向这个男主。
不要说那么长态。
只说一句，hello.
因为他只要说出这个哈楼，两个人就可以彼此确认对方身份了。呃，当然了，女方是不需要确定这个男方身份的，但是男方要确定这个女方的身份。
说句哈楼说句哈楼呢结束，但是呢当然了也会引发一个问题，就是我们这个女主她最纠结的我是谁，这件事情没有走出来，对吧？我那我们需要修改剧本的时候，就需要把这个把这件事情解决一下，为什么？因为我们知道人家创作者这么设计，人家也有人家的理由呀。
因为他最后问他，who are you吗？
所以说他必须把这个梗给圆上，那么就可以往前倒。也就是说这个女孩她走出了关于自己是谁这件事情，她最后一个漂流瓶是写上了自己的名字的，然后扔给了这个男主。然后这个由于扔的位置不好，让这个男主去购这个漂流瓶的时候，被城管发现了。
就是说我没有我没有明确的答案给到同学们啊，我们只是一种探讨。因为说哈楼，然后直接失漏掉，可以更有力量啊。
收说哈楼更直接收掉呢，可以给观众回味和遐想留白的空间更大。但是呢没有解决女主完全成长这个弧线的问题。
因为女主需要直面自己金是金玉莲这件事情，这是她的成长弧线。那么我们需要把这个弧线提前放在女主最后一次想要把漂流瓶扔给。
扔给男主的时候呢。
呃，已经晚了，男主被城管抓走，或者是男主因为最后这一个漂流瓶被城管抓走。
我们来设想一下这种改变的可能性，对吧？
开放式探讨啊，因为我当年在看这个电影的时候，我非常希望结束在哈lo，开始在哈lo结束在哈lo。然后呢，但是女主成长这个问题要不要管呢？当然要管呀。因为她不愿意面对自己是金玉莲这件事情，是整个故事是整个女主的这个人物弧线的最高潮。
那当然要解决，那可以放在。
他的最后一个漂流瓶去解决掉。但是最后这个漂流瓶，我是金玉莲这几个字。
没有能够传达到我们的男主手中，甚至让我们的男主因为最后这一个漂流瓶被城管给发现了，被驱干。
只是探讨一种可能性啊。
回到我们故事当中来，自己去想办法啊自己去想办法。
看剧本啊，一定要设想各种可能性。同学们，你们未来啊接触真正的创作的时候，你们就知道开剧本会的时候各种可能性都要探讨。
因为每一种可能性都有它的优点和弱点，都有牵一发而动全身的地方。所以说在日常的工作中，你们一定会遇到的。
这种情况。
大家要讨论各种可能性。
围绕这个故事。
我们来探讨几个故事点啊，探讨几个知识点。第一个知识点。
这个故事。
是什么类型？我提供两种思路啊？同学们，我提供两种思路。关于这个片子啊，我们有两种思路可以探讨，两种思路都可以都可以探讨。
我们说这个故事到底是不是爱情片？
或者是我们探讨这个故事到底是单主角还是双主角。假设这个故事是双主角，那么这个片子显然是爱情片啊吧？那么我们来看一下整个故事的脉络，用爱情片能不能理出来。
假设这个故事是爱情片，那么两个人相遇肯定是第一幕啊，两个人相遇是第一幕。
那第一幕就要打到。
第十一趴第34分钟。
我们先假设啊，同学们不用去不用去担心这个问题啊，我们先假设。
这个故事是双主角。
假设以爱情片的脉络，我们去看两个人各自出场，女主出的稍微晚一些，然后发现男主两个人相遇。
对吧两个人相遇。
是前十一盘来到第34分钟。
两个人试图取得联系，通过漂流瓶，通过这个这个这个这个沙滩上写字。
会来到了第。
60多分钟。
来到了第64分钟啊，两个人取得了联系，算是取得了进展。
然后后面两个人感情升温。
是吧但是呢也出现了误会，忽而又的误会破裂之后进入灵魂黑夜。
然后最后一部分呢，两个人相遇，真正的相爱。
啊，我们说假设他是双主角，以爱情片脉络的话，四幕式其实是。
拉的出来的啊。
同学们自己去记啊，我不是让你们去辩论的。
你们自己去思考，多学习啊。
电影这个东西没有标准答案啊，不需要有标准答案，也没有人批卷子。
看一下，假设男主。
是单一主角，那他的现状。
是他欠钱想死，他困在一个岛上之后啊，决定活下去，甚至向城市示威。
我们说他决定在一个孤岛上远离人间啊，远离现代文明的活下去，这是他的第一幕的目标啊，甚至他还脱衣服示威。我们说是一个非常有仪式感的目标，对吧？也就是前八拍是第一幕。
然后来到第九幕呃，第九第九拍捉鱼捉鸭呀、抓鸟掏蛋呀，开始了它的游戏时间。
也就是说，他选择在荒岛上远离文明生活啊，开始享受了比较极致的。
开始享受了生活了，尝到甜头啊，但是他这时候。
有一个新的目标就是炸酱面，然后再第。
67分钟也就24拍的时候，有人给他他的伙伴给他送来的炸酱面。
假设他是单男主啊，他在第二幕遇到了一个隔空的。
笔友伙伴。
给他送来的炸酱面。
这是个虚假的胜利，但是他不吃。
他需要自己去种。
然后呢，他种种出了炸酱面，但是呢也勾起了对。
现实社会的。
想念。
一个人在这里终究不是个办法，而且他还有一个值得牵挂的情感，也就是他的伙伴。
但是呢也进入了灵魂黑夜，他将要跟他的伙伴分离，他也要跟他的乌托邦，他跟他的乌托邦跟他的虚假的爱情全部要。
分离了。
也就是说第三幕的灵魂黑夜打点是不变的。
然后进到第四幕，我们的男主在现实生活当中一样可以收获女主的情感。
我们说在这种情况下。
单男主。
仪事变迁。
啊，变签仪式啊，这个你们怎么说都行。面对一个现实问题，采取了一个错误的解决方案，自杀嘛。我们说自杀一般是疑式变迁啊，一个现实问题采取了自杀或者是躲起来逃避这样一种解决方案，这种故事是非常典型的仪式变迁啊，这个是不需要去讨论的。
同学们自己选。
如果是双主角，两个人的相识，互补互助共谋，误会决裂患难真情是基本完整的。
对吧我们说这这个故事感情线是基本完整的。如果是双主角，那就是伙伴之情，两个人双向奔赴，各只不过是两个人各自的线都是仪式变迁，两个仪式变迁凑成一个伙伴之情。
如果你把他看成是那单男主的仪式变迁，那么女主就是他第二幕出现的一个伙伴，辅助她成长。只不过这个伙伴戏份比较多，而且这个伙伴呢自己也有一个完整的成长活件。
同学们理解我们为什么要把这两种方案都剖析一遍吗？
实际上为啥这么说啊？
是不是都跑得通啊？同学们。
我咱们调查一下咱们同学们的啊。
呃，我先给你结论，就是两个方案其实都跑得通。
两个方案都跑得通，你说他是伙伴，也跑得通，说他是变签仪式，也能切得出私募，说是伙伴也能切得出私募都跑得。
但是你们更倾向于什么？
我看一下。
你们更倾向于什么呢？更倾向于伙伴，还是更倾向于变迁呢？
你们更倾向于什么？。
没有答案啊没有答案，你们千万不要说我说的就是标准答案。
因为呃按不同的类型理解，你四目是切的位置都不一样。第一幕第二幕。
切的位置不一样。
你知道吧？第一幕第二幕那个打点位置就不一样了，灵魂黑夜和第四幕是一样的。
那我说一下我的感受好不好？
我认为啊。
基本上。
差不多就是变迁和伙伴之行。
这个份额基本上差不多1比1。但如果非要说谁控股，比如说51%、49%控股的话，我觉得疑世变迁控股就是单男主的疑世变迁可能占个5050几的股份。
这个伙伴之情呢占个百分之。
四八了四十9的股份，反正变迁一是控股了。
这是我一个观点。
我们再来看一下嗯双主角啊，不管他呃哦这两个角色的设定啊，不管他是双主角，还是说单男主，女主，女主是男主的一个爱情线。不管是什么啊，这两个角色它肯定是互补的角色，对不对？
从这节课开始，请所有的同学给我深刻的理解一下。我让你们写互补主角的时候，很多同学就卯足了劲儿了写这两个人所有东西都是反义词。
同学们看一下这两个角色。
我们说这两个角色当然是非常标准的互补，因为是爱情嘛，因为是是是互相治愈嘛。
但是两个人的共通点实际上是非常。
一个人生活在。
现实中的孤岛。
一个人生活在网络上的孤岛。
当然有互补，一男一女，一个是打拼的人，一个是宅女，对吧？一个家庭条件不好，一个家庭条件好。
一个被被被被被人抛弃，一个被被人宠爱。
互补的东西当然有，但是他们的共通点就是。
生活在孤岛上。
两个人都生活在孤岛上。
课后作业啊，同学们把这两个角色好好的剖析剖析，好好的剖析剖析。为什么好好的剖析剖析？
因为这个女主的角色就是咱们很多同学在日常练习的时候特别喜欢写的一种角色，所谓的社恐。
同学们，你们在写写写故事的写人设的时候，经常给我搞一个社恐的谁谁。
来学一学教科书版的社恐咋写。
我经常说你们写的社恐啊。
这个这个不到位，同学们，你们自己去。
后后你们下课以后自己去给我复盘一下这个女主涉恐的细节，她写了多少？
住在衣柜里。
强迫症。
那个爱捏泡泡，同学们捏泡泡。
然后房间里全是垃圾，我跟你说，社恐的人，房间里全是垃圾。
然后呢，但是呢同时又极度自律，这上哪说理去？
然后为了避免跟别人眼神交流，什么头盔呀、雨伞呀。
同学们，你们去研究一下。
这个社恐他写的有多么的极致。
学一学啊，以后不要把社恐这种人设啊就停留在嘴上，再来学一下下一个知识点。
我们说不管这个故事是不是伙伴之情为主或者是爱情为主。
他的爱情线都是很完整的啊，同学们自己去看一下他的相识，他的互补。
对吧相识我们说非常有仪式感的相识，偶然发现啊，因为因为什么相识啊，因为防空演习啊，因为防空演习这一天，两个人在男主跳河的第一天就相识了。
是吧然后来互补。
互补啊，甚至有互助。
这个男生呢影响了这个女孩，让这个女孩也看到了一些生活的希望。这个女孩呢也去帮助这个男主。
也给他信心啊，给他支撑支撑。然后后来呢两个人有共谋啊，一起这个种玉米，一起吃炸酱面。
然后嘞。
后面因为最初我们说产生误会都是因为最初的问题啊，最初的问题，最初的困境。
主角最初的缺陷在误会处爆发，主角最初的缺陷就是他不知道自己是谁，因为他一直假装成另外一个人嘛。
所以说误会就是who are you这个男生认为自己问了一个非常正常的问题，但是导致这个女生精神世界直接崩塌。who are you.
然后两导致两个人决裂了啊，互相拉黑，或者是说这个女的单方面拉黑了这个男的，对吧？关上窗帘，拆掉望远镜，拉黑了这个男的。
然后怎么样见真情呢？患难啊，这个女男主再一次被抓回现实社会，准备再次去去送死的时候。
产生了危难啊，患难之后，这个女生不顾一切。
不怕阳光了，也不怕这个外面的世界了，不怕汽车了是吧？不怕上街了。
见患难见真情。
爱情八步走啊，自己同学们自己也去打一下点。
再来看一下知识点。
来，我看我们看一组。
중력처럼 예쁜내리로 가벼워.
.
心给。
我们说像这种镜头，包括它溺水的那组蒙太奇镜头啊，是一种呃非常梦幻的一种处理方式啊，一种超限的处处理方式。
嗯，咱们有很多同学啊咱们有很多同学，特别是上了年纪的一部分同学啊，就像我这种上了一部分年上了一定年纪的同学啊，呃是不喜欢这种风格的。在这里我先强调一下啊。
在这里我要强调一下。
咱们搞创作的人啊，一定要有个宏观概宏观概念啊。
嗯，也就是说在有一代中国人啊，就咱们中国的观众，在有一代中国观众里面会有一种强烈的审美偏好，就是觉得不真实的东西就是不好的。
我们经常看一个影视作品啊，特别是呃有一部分观众看一个影视作品，经常会说哎这个不真实就不好看，不真实，所以不好看。
就这个东西有有魔幻色彩，有梦幻色彩，所以不好看。
这是非常多的一部分观众啊呃这个这个这个遗留下来的一个审美偏好。
呃，为什么要专门强调这个东西呢？我希望咱们的同学都要打破这个审美偏好，为什么呢？因为新一代的观众是没有这个问题的。
我们来剖析一下我们为什么会有这个偏好啊，是因为第一，当然跟我们的民族性有关系啊，我们相对比较压抑。
不太喜欢花里胡哨的东西。
啊，相对审美也好，生活也好，比较压抑。
比较不喜欢这个花里胡哨的东西，好吧，这是我们的第一个原因。
第二个原因。
就是影视作品这个东西啊就影视作品这个东西啊。
呃，进入我国的时候啊进入我国的时候，在我国的发展路径啊，就是就是这样的，以务实为美啊，以现实为美。
所以会导致我们相当一部分观众呃一部分像我这样这一代成长起来的观众呢就会有这样的审美偏好。
为什么说我们作为创作者，我们要打破这个观念呢？
是因为呃绝大部分的观众，特别是年轻观众已经没有这个问题了。
因为现代影视作品对于年轻观众来说，他非常明确的知道这是个影视作品，这是一个娱乐产品，它是给我带来欢乐的。
而不像我们当年看一个片子，非常要求非常较真儿的，希望它是真的，对吧？我非常较真儿啊，呃，也导致我们一代人都欣赏不了这个。
都欣赏不了印度片是吧？
我们有一代人很多人欣赏不了印度片，总觉得印度片动不动就唱起歌来跳起舞来很傻很蠢啊。其实不是的啊，说明人家印度人在很早就把电影啊当成了一种。
娱乐产品休闲产品对吧？那那里面加上我喜欢的东西也没有什么不好。
懂吗？
就像你看短视频也好。
你不会觉得短视频都是必须是真的对吧？假的，我不看对吧？没有这个必要啊，没有这个必要。所以说这是一种审美偏好啊，这是一种审美偏好。呃，我没有我没有说哪一种好与不好的意思，我只是想告诉我们所有的创作者呃，不要有这个问题啊，不要有这个问题呃。
你自己去呃，你如果走不出你的偏好啊，你很有可能创作面就很窄，为啥呢？因为你的偏好未必是主流偏好啊。
这个同学们要把认知提高到这个层面啊。
把认知提起来啊把认知提起来。
能明白我在说什么吗？明白的扣个一啊，我没有我没有改变你们审美的意思，你们爱怎么审美怎么审美。我只是告诉你们在创作的时候。
自己要心里有点数。
不要觉得你喜欢什么，就是主流的，你有很你有非你有非常大的可能性，很不主流。所以说啊那这个故事我们就比较明确了，如果是。
如果是按照单男主去理解，那么我们这个故事探讨的就是一个男人在欠债啊，走投无路的情况下想要逃避这个社会。结果呢呃在一个荒岛上啊，他如何要生存下去这么一个故事。
然后来，他探讨的主题无疑就是关于希望啊关于这个这个这个呃生活的意义啊，生活的希望。
然后呢。
嗯嗯，里面有非常明确的一个比喻，我们知道在诗里面有人写过啊，说呃人啊孤独的像一座岛啊，记不记得有这个诗啊，孤独的像一座岛啊。
在这个在这部电影里面啊，非常非常完美的诠释了。
嗯，两个主角呃两个角色啊，一个角色生活在真的岛上。而且这个岛为什么当年说很有创意啊？我们说他如果真的是个荒岛，那也就那也就。
那也就没什么太大的意思了啊，它在它是城市当中的一座岛，这个比喻非常明确了啊，就是我在繁华的都市当中，我依然活得像一座古岛。
就是在繁华的都市当中。
都市的繁华与我无关啊。所以说这个戏不管是从利益上，还是从这个画面冲击力上。
这个创意实在是太美好了啊，这个创意实在是太棒了。
孤独的像一座岛啊，都市当中的岛。
而且后面他加上这个神来之笔，这个防空演习啊，从春天到秋天，从播种到收获，这个防空演习也实在是太美妙了啊太美妙了。
关于这个故事，我们探讨两个问题。
我们探讨两个问题。
第一个问题。
如果这个剧本。
在我们手里，我们要做汉化改造，做本土化改造。
都有哪些地方是需要做本土化的？
如果这个故事啊给到我们。
我们现在拿到咱们手里，我们要翻拍。
都哪些地方要做本土化改造防空警报。
炸酱面炸酱面改饺子，这个没有什么意义吧。
炸酱面改饺子应该是没有什么意义吧。
没有没有什么那个。
其他的选择吧。
炸酱面改成饺子是吧？肯定是没有其他的选择了。
醋包。
南方同学说汤圆。
汤圆也行吗？我是北方人啊，sorry,我我有本味主义了，那就饺子或汤圆啊，尊重一下南方的同学。
做月饼吧。
但是没有人喜欢吃月饼吗？会有人喜欢吃月饼吗？
嘿嘿嘿嘿。
酸辣粉有点过分了啊。
好吧。
可以，大家这个敞开讨论啊，防空演习怎么改啊，时间节点怎么卡，我们可没有一春一秋的这个防空演习，对吧？防空演习这个时间点怎么卡？
然后这个湖心岛要不要动是吧？长江还是黄河或者是什么江汉江上的一个呃，不是汉江那个汉江又上他们了长江黄河还是什么上的一个湖心岛要不要改啊？
防空演习这个怎么动，这个时间节点怎么卡？
卡成什么呢？
卡成春节还是卡成什么是吧？
卡放烟花的一天是吧？春节放烟花还是说什么想想看啊，同学们自己去琢磨琢磨，如果做本土化改造。
这些关键节点啊，时间节点对吧？防控演习这个重要的时间节点。
然后湖心岛这个场景。
然后那个炸酱面这个主目标主线目标分别怎么改，同学们自己去琢磨琢磨。
思考第二个问题。
怎么上来就说很难改呀。
好改还用你改啊，这不就肯定得挑战吗？
思考第二个问题。
这部电影不管是从当年来说啊，不管是从当年还是说从这个这个市场这呃，不管是从韩国当年的情况，还是咱国内的影评啊。
很多人在看这个女主这条线的时候啊。
觉得。
不得劲儿，因为女主这条线说实话，戏份一点儿不比男主少。
我们想一想女主这条线到底出了什么问题，到底还有什么地方可以优化？
是这个角色不可爱，太矫情了，还是说这个角色选的不够难看？
同学们，如果让你优化女主这条线。
首先你确定一下女主这条线。
能能不能能不能优化，或者是你共情度可不可以，对吧？
然后想一想女主这条线还能不能优化。
当然有很多同学会觉得呃很好啊，因为网络时代嘛，现在网络时代比当年要自闭的人要多啊，所以说共情会会多一些。
但是当年啊很多人会认为女性这女主这条线啊略有点矫情。对，为什么要观察男主这个动机也可以加强啊，也可以加强。同学们，这我们是敞开讨论啊，如果女主这条线我们需要把它加强一下。
怎么加强？
啊，都有哪些地方？
是有优化空间的。
放开思考啊，我们说这是两个思考的问题，第一个是本土化，第二个是女主这条线怎么优化？对，接触外星人这个原因是吧？我们也确实确实共情不了。
接就是他发现外星人，所以很感兴趣，这些这个这条线吧也确实有点，我也是觉得有点怪怪。
对大家敞开想没有什么关系啊，没有什么对错。
这些问题放在课后思考，我们来讲这节课最重要的一个知识点就是我们遇到变签意识怎么去打点。
怎么写？
回到我们。
拉片学习最重要的一个环节啊，我们以后遇到同类型，我们想写一个。
很惨的主角，或者他遇到生活当中解决不了的问题，我们要写变签仪式了，打点怎么打来。
从这个电影当中我们学到的最重要的啊最重要的。第一，上来主角遇到一个困境，先交代。
困境。
第二。
主角选择逃避这个困境。
第三。
主角逃避这个困境之后。
意外获得甜头。
对吧逃避这个困境就是自杀，自杀得到了荒岛上，意外获得甜头了，觉得哎还不错呢。
活的还挺好啊，第三步获得甜筒。
第四步，在有甜头的生活环境下产生一个目标。
第五。
为了这个目标付出努力，经受磨练。
在家给我记住，一定要经受磨练。
因为这个关系到他后面回到现实当中啊，经受磨练。经受完磨练之后，他的这个目标成功了。
一切都很美好，对吧？逃避到另外一个世界，获得甜头，树立目标，经历磨练，然后还成功了达成目标了。
然后摧回去。
而且摧毁的非常突然。
摧毁他非常无情的在另外一个虚假的世界建立的目标以及成果，摧毁完这个。
摧毁完这个成果之后，他要回到现实。
回到现实，回到原本的生活轨迹上。
但是同学们记住，这时候他有个什么东西不一样了。
他在另外一个世界经历过磨练了。
他成长。
所以他回到现实之后，可能也会短暂受挫，但是他经历的磨练和成长让他真正的回归了。
理解我在说什么吗？九个步骤啊九个步骤，困境逃避，甜头目标磨练成功摧毁啊，摧摧毁，然后回到现实，带着成长。
9个步骤啊，我们说从这个剧本啊。
从这个剧本来说啊，从这个剧本来说，实际上会比汤姆汉克斯的那个。
那个叫荒岛余生吧，叫是叫荒岛余生吧。汤姆汉克斯。
我们说如果是大家认为，因为荒岛余生跟这个片子完全不是一个类型啊，我们说荒岛余生还是一个逃脱的故事，这个是一个变迁仪式啊，这个剧本实际更加严谨。有同学说有点像。
录取通知，那不废话吗？
像录取通知，那不废话吗？
那怎么可能不像录取通知呢？我想请问你们。
是吧他不可能像荒岛余生，但是他一定向录取通知。
对吧一定会向录取通知呀。
这个剧本啊。
大家再去体会一下，非常的严谨啊非常的严谨啊，嗯写的是非常棒。虽然从故事类型上给了了我们一定小小的争议啊，但是这个在咱们嗯学习中，我们也我们也反复强调啊类型这个东西啊，在切刀的时候啊，它总是能切到中间，特别像那种好的东西啊这么。
这种好剧本拿在手里。
你不觉得可以反复把玩吗？就这个故事，你不觉得可以反复把玩吗？
很有余味呀，是不是很有很有味道的，对不对？
好吧。
那这节课我想给大家讲的就是这么多啊，学会对新学的套路嘛。
就是要学点新套路啊，每一次都要学点新套路啊。
多去多去品味一下这种故事。嗯嗯嗯我给你们留的那个思考题啊，女主这条线呀，或者是做做本土化呀，自己在脑子里面推演推演呃，练习练习好不好？假设这个故事落在你手里啊。
好吧，那这节课就到这儿了。
。
当当。